thoughts on adding sulforophane to my regimen.
So, sulforophane is a great product and could ever, could,
would sulforophane be good for everybody?
I would say that would be one,
sulforophane would, one of those nutrients that probably would fit into that category.
I mean, I have favorite supplements like nerve reading, medicinal mushrooms,
things like that, curcumin, anti-inflammatories, the flavonoids.
All those are favorite supplements because there could be good for anybody, right?
Well, sulforophane could fit into that category.
Oh, understand, when I do cheek swab testing,
I want to test what's going to be specific for you.
And if sulforophane doesn't come up positive on that,
does that mean that if you're really praying about it,
you really feel glad that you should add that,
but you shouldn't because it didn't come up positive on the cheek swab test.
Well, no, I, again, I want you to feel like you could,
you're making your own decisions, you're praying about your own care.
But I also don't want you to be making decisions based upon fear
or some new Instagram posts you saw.
It's, you know, read it.
I was just talking about this about CBD.
And there's a question about CBD later on about how it's all over the internet about this
or all over the internet about that.
And people are watching these Instagram posts or these Facebook posts
or they, these tick-tax videos where it's basically a somebody who claims
to be a nutritionist or claims to be a naturopath.
But really, they're just out there pedaling supplements.
Now, again, that's far be it for me to have a problem with somebody trying to earn a living
and doing what they think is right.
But again, I just think it's so ethically wrong
to just be pushing supplements and saying that everybody should take this
or these grandiose false highly falsified claims
that many of these influencers make to push a supplement.
Like she was reading, was talking about it's all over the internet
about this CBD product where CBD take you to weight pain.
And that is actually a question that we're going to talk about in just a couple of minutes
because somebody asked that it takes CBD for pain.
Well, CBD is not the thing you would take for pain.
So it's just, there's a lot of misrepresentation in the nutritional field.
You know, years ago we used to bash the practice of medicine
because there's a lot of misrepresentation in the medical field with drugs.
But it's almost worse than the alternative spectrum now.
It's just really sad.
And so just be careful of that.
So thoughts on adding so horrifying to my resume.
I can't remember who asked this question.
By all means, if you feel like God's leading you to do that,
then I'm not here to tell you about to do that.
But I didn't come up.
It didn't come up in the cheek swab.
I don't think that I would do that.
So it's you can make your own decisions.
But I'm not, don't just search the internet for the next greatest thing
or then listen to some influencers who's trying to push it.
I will supplement.